jacques hébert a suivi les travaux des
dirigeants communistes c'est d'après
midi ce comité central véritable
parlement du parti communiste qui
regroupe plus de 100 personnes avaient
en fait pour tâche de préparer le 20ème
congrès du pc qui doit se tenir au mois
de décembre prochain à st tôt hier et
aujourd'hui place du colonel fabien on a
donc parlé de ce congrès mais aussi des
problèmes d'actualité et pour monsieur
georges marchais il l'a dit au cours
d'une conférence de presse l'entreprise
des réformateurs de messieurs le canoë
et servan-schreiber ne vise qu à
replâtrer le régime actuel la seule
alternative c'est le programme commun de
gouvernement avec les socialistes et les
radicaux de gauche toutefois at il
ajouté il ne faut pas se limiter à ces
alliances notre comité central lance un
nouvel appel
non seulement au parti socialiste et aux
radicaux de gauche avec qui nous sommes
en discussion
mais aussi aux grandes organisations
syndicales à toutes les organisations
sociales à tous les français et les
françaises qui aspire un véritable
changement
nous sommes prêts nous communistes
amené avec eux en faveur du programme
commun une action commune dont l'ampleur
répondent aux exigences de la situation
actuelle
nous voulons collaborer
sur un pied d'égalité et dans un esprit
authentiquement démocratique avec toutes
les forces
désireuse d'agir pour le renouveau
démocratique du pays